hi i'm lisa ann and i am back to answer
the internet would you rather your pet
have a dog's personality in a cat body
or a cat's personality in a dog body why
are you slow rolling me right now when i
know the weird questions are coming i'll
take the cats personality in the dog
body because it would be more chill and
i would feel less guilty about leaving
it home for long periods of time but
that was like would you rather fart only
once a year but it's the worst smell in
the world and you smell like it for two
weeks or fart like you do now and it
doesn't smell but colored gas comes out
of your ass
i would [ __ ] love it if colored gas
came out of my ass i would find that
that would be a great deterrent for
people creeping on me like following me
when i'm walking in the city i feel them
heavy breathing in my ear i know they're
about to make the approach and try and
get a photo would it be great just build
a fart and just like blue gas comes out
they're gone i'll take it
would you rather go back to being 18
years old knowing everything you know
now or get a million dollars i would go
back to being 18 years old knowing
everything i know now because i could
make a million dollars a year
this knowledge easily a lot of things
letting people with sneekly stick things
in my butt a lot of things would you
rather live in a world without
headphones or a world without doors
would you rather live in a world without
headphones or a world without doors
definitely would rather live in a world
without headphones i need doors to shut
out the world would you rather have the
ability to see through cards when
gambling or get 150 million i think
everybody would probably want the
hundred and fifty million because you'd
be afraid that you could get caught
seeing through the cards right but it'd
be fun to travel all around the world
and see-through cards and win at
gambling kind of [ __ ] you money right
it's just [ __ ] you we all want it's [ __ ]
you money you could make 150 mine would
you rather go 50 years in the future or
50 years
in the past I'd rather go 50 years in
the past the style the manners the lack
of free porn on the internet who would
be the world's most dominant one-on-one
basketball player if everyone was forced
to play naked who would be the world's
most dominant one-on-one basketball
player if everyone was forced to play
naked I would definitely say John Salley
because he has the biggest penis I've
ever seen in my life yeah it's like this
it's an arm okay it's an arm would you
rather the world lost women or all
sports so you're asking me to switch it
to men gosh what would we do without men
or women but what would we do without
sports I'm gonna make the human decision
here and say I'd rather the world lost
all sports because I don't want to give
up men or women if you could get
shit-faced with any of us president who
would it be if you could get [ __ ] faced
with any US president who would it be I
think I'd go back to the Kennedys I
think I'd go yeah I'd go with Kennedy
can you still go to your barber if he's
very racist I mean should you interact
with anyone who's racist but if we all
believe in free speech like we're
supposed to other people's opinions or
student be valued as their opinions you
don't have to agree with it but in this
actual image he is wearing the full
thing so I would say for this guy no so
if I walked in my stylist was dressed
like that I'd be like not a good day
but if I didn't know this is why I only
let Russians touch my hair and I make
sure that they don't speak much English
so I don't really have to get to know
them so I take a book in LA my salads
were Russian
and I found my Russian place here in New
York and I'm super stoked guys like we
were using Google Translate I'm like I'm
so happy we don't have to talk in order
for you to live you have to kill a blind
child who has the greatest voice of our
generation are you killing the kid in
order for me to live I'd kill a blind
child who has the greatest voice of our
generation I'm always gonna live I'm
killing the kid I'm killing anybody over
me it's do or die
you're dying I promise you that I will
kill a fan eventually I promise you cuz
I my biggest fear is being attacked by a
fan my friends all think I'm gonna die
from a stalker right and I always tell
them like no this stalkers gonna die
it's kind of like you guys getting in
trouble that'd be great for my street
cred and I think less people would [ __ ]
with me I think you'd be like I have a
harder time getting away with it there's
cameras everywhere now I've thought this
through I have to wait until they
approach me I mean the emails and mail I
get is probably enough that could lead
me to go to that person I had a guy that
twice this past year two people fake
purchased me on the internet for a
marriage and gave hundreds of thousands
of dollars these stupid scammer
Instagram fake profiles and showed up at
my gigs and told the people at the door
they were there to take me home like
they literally thought they purchased me
so those are the ones where I think I
could probably get away and that first
guy he would call my radio show and on
breaks my producers will come on be like
yo Larry keeps calling and asking us if
you're telling us you guys are married
yet
like yeah so that's the guy if you could
only have four teeth in your entire
mouth where would they be I mean I guess
you 140 if is gonna look stupid up front
only four I don't eat meat so I really
don't need my back teeth so I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna go all four on the top
and just have a specific smile you know
like that car I like the weird smile
I'll keep those two you gun to your head
you have to pick one food
for your boyfriend to chew up and spit
in your mouth what would it be
Pizza if you if you put in the microwave
it tastes like that anyway like you ever
heat it up in the microwave that's why
you have issues that is weird
you're kidding wait for the oven to heat
up doesn't it make it right I'd rather
eat up coals and put it in the microwave
because that's [ __ ] weird would you
rather go into a coma and not wake up
until you're 75 or die tomorrow
that's a good question would you rather
go into a coma not wake up to you're 75
or died tomorrow I think I'd rather die
tomorrow I mean who's gonna take care of
me what kind of hospital situation I can
be in for all these years
what a burden I don't want to be a
burden I'll die tomorrow if you could
wipe out one group of people off the
earth who would it be I am going to wipe
out all the people that don't pay for
porn set in narrow it down to one group
think I did fine
you